hello  you're in great danger get out of that  now open safe house 6 welcome in the  Townsend agency  I run a covert group of exceptional  women  you guys are like lady spies we work  outside the rules in secret together  you may not know we exist but we are  always watching oh you are in the  presence of angels so you might have  trained to be an angel  Holly ah give me my wings  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  sit down and keep your hands where I can  see them really not supposed to be  touching things in here unless you're  supposed to be touching things with you  you're adorable J is about you flirting  with a handsome nerd  [Music]  the best part is impatient down  international criminals  with you guys  and the day drinking that's what I like  the most  [Music]  so I can just take whatever I want Baro  is that an actual rule  [Music]  ain't no time to go to work  [Music]  you